bring in Reggie Miller the hall-of-famer
I'm curious reg what you thought of the
so-called janky defense that Toronto was
playing with the Box in one on Steph
Curry
actually that was pretty brilliant to
tell you the truth because it's really
stifled and surprised Steve Kerr and the
Warriors and with the injuries mounting
for Golden State and really having one
legitimate shooter not necessarily
player because boogie was on the floor
but one legitimate shooter on the floor
why not and it surprised Golden State
and the problem was Toronto couldn't
make shot that the other end yeah so
their defense was pretty good in that
box of one they just couldn't score at
the other end so if on both teams I'm
pretty happy about Game two for the
Warriors to be able to split regain
recapture home court advantage being
short-handed going back to the day one
one I'm happy if I'm Toronto I'm saying
to myself we are up big early we
couldn't make shots our defense was as
good as it's been throughout these
playoffs we've got to find ways to make
shots so I think they're feeling pretty
good come Wednesday in Game three
obviously with the scene changing I
think the big question mark is going to
be who's going to be available and at
what strength I mean the injuries are
mounting and it's going to be something
that Steve Kerr is going to have to
really do a good job
I mean people keep talking about the
Warriors bench or non-existent bench I
think they were pretty good down the
stretch and boogie cousins to do what he
did after that kind of layoff was really
impressive I'm curious how he feels
today after being out there in a game as
opposed to in a practice and how
effective he'll be on Wednesday because
it'll be all hands on deck if you don't
have KD I don't know how healthy clay is
going to be an MRI this morning you know
but at least you're at home and you know
Golden State will still be favored I
think they're favored by like six or
seven points
going back home and throwing Kevon loony
with the shoulder injury you know so
it's interesting you know you talk about
the injuries and all hands on deck it's
boogie cousins this is his chance to
shine and for a guy that's never been to
the playoffs and to be on the biggest
stage and has that type of performance
with as long as lay over and the
injuries think about the injuries he's
coming back from I mean these are
significant injuries and to have a
fingerprint and to have a say in that
game was remarkable but again if I'm
Toronto I'm feeling pretty good I really
am I'm not saying that they're gonna go
into the area and probably still won but
he's got to make shots they have to make
shots and I know as a shooter I've never
really had a hamstring injury so if
you're clay he's saying he's okay but it
affects your movement your rhythm and as
much as clay plays off the basketball
and as much running as he does
throughout the game that hamstring is
going to be tested how do you explain
the third quarter for the Warriors and
in particular Steph Curry that's his
best quarter of all four quarters he
averages nine points per third quarter
in every game but is it just a
coincidence that Golden State seems to
adjust and come out and that third
quarter is just like a tidal wave no I
think if you go back and you look at the
statistics the third quarter has always
been the Warriors quarters it's almost
like they take two quarters to kind of
figure you out and then they come with
the overhand right in the third quarter
so that if you go back and you look at
you know through third quarters are
probably the best probably along with
Houston I just think it takes them a
while to figure it out and to go on an
1800 run to start the third in the NBA
Finals that's pretty significant and I
think it caught Toronto on their heels
but again it was still a one-possession
game before
if you doll had knocked down that big
three so as well as they played in the
third quarter Toronto was hanging around
talking to Reggie Miller NBA on TNT and
listen of course hall-of-famer you know
with the Rockets maybe cleaning house
here and you know do you keep James
Harden and build around him do you keep
Mike D'Antoni and continue to have that
system here you know my thought with the
Rockets I don't know how you feel is I'd
sort of like to see where Kauai ends up
I'd like to see what happens with Golden
State before I start to make these
wholesale changes but if I think the
Lakers would take Chris Paul off my
hands and they would offer up
Lonzo ball and maybe the fourth pick
overall and I jump on that if I'm
Houston what are your thoughts elute Lee
absolutely I would do that you get a
chance to get younger you will be
obviously picking you know this is a
pretty good draft the fourth draft pick
would be pretty significant again you
get younger I agree with waiting to see
where the chips are gonna fall come you
know June 30th July 1st where everyone's
thinking about going but if you think
about this them not reciting or
extending Mike D'Antoni it's almost like
they're writing on the walls that this
system is not for us anymore it's high
octane we score a lot of points it's
good to watch during the regular season
some playoffs as we know it doesn't
translate so for them not to extend Mike
D'Antoni let's not forget he was coach
of the year last season yeah I thought
to the year but can you win with James
Harden
I believe you can because if you look at
how the rules are today you've got to
have someone who could put the ball in
the basket you can certainly do that he
has done a great job when they were
short-handed when Chris Paul was out
last year and he went on that thirty
point barrage for about a month straight
and got them back into the top four at
one point yeah you got to have a guy
that can score the basketball I just
think he needs to be surround
by better players it to me the system
that system just is not getting it done
during the playoffs yeah I'm just trying
to figure out what they do and if you
know Chris Paul making that kind of
money and if I can clear that salary cap
and then maybe I can get a free agent to
come to town I just don't know if you're
a free agent would you rather play with
James Harden or LeBron James I would
probably say wow that is a that's a
tough one because there are so many
expectations was playing with the Lakers
now and not knowing what's going on in
the hierarchy or that front office to me
that's just that's a tornado you know
you just don't know but look how many
years left is LeBron have at that level
I know he's signed for three more years
but you got how old is the harden 30
yeah just turning 30 I think I probably
got to say James Harden because he's
younger there's so much turmoil with the
Lakers right now I don't know what's
going on with that that organization I
really don't I don't know if they know
what's going on there either but you
know I think they're both difficult
players to play with because there's a
lot that goes with playing with LeBron
and his team you know and being nervous
if you don't pass him you know I sort of
like what guys played with Jordan you
know you had to know what to do when to
do it and make sure you didn't
disappoint Mike and then you got harden
who you know is gonna do all those ISOs
and there's no ball movement whatsoever
and you sort of have to go oh you threw
it to me okay and it would be difficult
to play with both of those players as
great as they are I would kind of love
to see James Harden in like a Golden
State system where the ball moves clicks
there's a lot of ball movement he's
running off you know single doubles with
motion action quick hitters but why
don't they do that Ridge well not
everyone has the personnel but they've
got some shooters they you know they got
stand still Corner three shooters you
I don't have klay Thompson type shooters
they don't have Kevin Durant take you
off the dribble type shooters and scores
yeah the guys their personnel run to the
short corner three dribble isolation and
when the defense collapses I have five
guys on me then I'll kick it to you I
kind of want to see him in a more
free-flowing offense but not there's not
a lot of coaches that do I mean I kind
of like to see them in the San Antonio
office with Gregg Popovich free-flowing
everyone touches the basketball yeah I
don't think we're gonna see that the
rest James Harden's career where it's a
free-flowing offense there the coach as
well maybe Mike D'Antoni comes back next
year and may change the script but again
this is just not Mike D'Antoni because
remember they like those analytics this
is journal Morley as well right so this
is your general manager slash president
who has this ideology as well so we had
a poll question last week if I said you
could know one team's roster for next
season the start of next season you
could know that roster right now which
team would you want to know what their
roster was going to be and only that one
team I would probably want to know
there's a lot of questions that are
coming out of Golden State will Katie
stay will clay stay where they can do
with boogie cousins I would kind of want
to know what Golden State's going to do
because it could be a new look Golden
State team we're just stuff they're
really or it could be a team if they
find their way to three-peat it could be
a team that says all right we're all
going to be back in maybe four short
term contract to see if we can go for
four in a row what showed me and people
don't understand this after the game
when Katie and clay or outside the
locker room greeting the guys as they
were coming in and they kind of got into
that back-and-forth with Drake people to
understand the camaraderie that players
have with one another because people
want to signal out Katie he's not all in
that little clip of those guys out there
waiting both injured both her clay had
ice on his hamstring and there outside
the locker room and their gapping up
everyone it's those little clips what I
I take away from that
these guys they care for one another
they're all in for one another
and I don't think they're listening to
the white noise of all of us saying okay
T's he's he's on his way to me I think
KT is more in than we think he's in with
Golden State I really do just by looking
at that little clip could you see Kauai
and KD take one-year deals I could I
really could I'm not so much Kauai
because I think clients been so
non-committal to Toronto but he's done
he is the king of the north now but I
just can't see it to have all these
players in the West I mean right now you
only you would only have Yanis really
out east you gotta have some stars in
the Eastern Conference but I could see
Katy taking a one-year deal if Golden
State finds the wait at the repeat in
them trying to go for a 4-peat and I
bring this up let's say Golden State
does win another title but KD doesn't
win the title he's not on the floor with
them does that have any impact I know we
like to look at resume and legacy do we
is that held against him in in so on oh
absolutely not because up until that
point of that injury we were saying he
was the best player in the playoffs at
that time correct him in maybe Kauai up
until that point up until that injury
Katie was the best player in the
playoffs it wasn't even a question so
even if go to state three Pete's and he
has a small hand in it that counts
that's know yeah absolutely now it's not
like he missed you know half the season
no just like boogie cousins him coming
back this is significant for him and and
going forward I mean because if I'm if
I'm a an organization and I'm looking at
boogie cousins because people always
want to talk about it
attitude think about the mental
toughness mental toughness it has taken
for him to come back from two
significant injuries just to compete he
just wants to be on the floor to help
his teammates if I'm a general manager a
president and owner I kind of want guys
like that I want guys like that that are
willing I want to beg a guy to go out
and play hard I want guys that have it
from within
boo-ki has it from within but also you
know I'm trying to figure out he wants
to get paid and Boogie's not gonna get
paid in Golden State which means he's
gonna be available for somebody I don't
know if somebody has seen enough out of
him that they would go okay because if
you're bringing him in you're gonna have
to spend some money on boogie cousins I
don't know if you could open up the bank
I could also see him on a one-year deal
another it's almost like a free show for
a year to see how you know he holds up
how how his body holds up with Golden
State with Golden State but you're right
there is gonna be a team see if there's
also teams to that will just throw money
to break up your team as well so there
could be a team that offers them a
three-year deal at sixty million do you
think the Lakers are gonna be interested
in boogie cousins they could but does
that fit the stuff I don't know what
their style is I thought their style was
surround the Brawn with shooters and
they didn't they didn't do that well we
got to see how old brake bull gold will
excuse me / LeBron James since he will
be the de-facto coaches / Jason Kidd /
Jason Kidd correct so we don't know what
again what's a lot of a you know the
Rambis is and buses you know there's a
lot of there's a lot of head coach
there's a lot of that coaches there you
know what I would just call him Frank
Laveau GLE you know from LeBron they're
just calling one one name oh you're not
writing vogue actually I do
head coach of the Lakers Laveau go go go
yeah instead of the logo you know it's
just Laveau go go yeah yeah would you
want to play with the Lakers right now
if you were let's say 31 years of eight
thirty years of age no who would you
want to play for let's say you're Kauai
I would play for Doc Rivers and the
Clippers I would play for Gregg Popovich
in the Spurs
I would play for Nick nurse in Toronto I
would play for Mike Budenholzer and the
Milwaukee Bucks Steve Kerr and their
Golden State Warriors and I would
probably play for Monty Williams and the
Phoenix ends mm-hmm at age 50 though who
do you want to play for Houston because
all I have to do is run to that short
corner three and I'll have the frame yet
the other so as 33g students my team
yeah I know you got to run hey thanks
we'll talk to you soon thank you buddy
that's Reggie Aloysius Miller jr. the
third Hall of Famer Turner sport NBA
analyst for more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
streamed for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]